[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro d' europe hebdo ici au
parlement européen à strasbourg dans
cette édition cap au nord de l'europe en
suède qui affiche la transition
énergétique la plus avancée de l'union
européenne avec près de 54 % d'énergie
renouvelable là bas les bus roulent au
biocarburant depuis une dizaine d'années
et une taxe carbone a été introduite dès
nos reporters sont allés enquêter sur ce
système vertueux à l'heure où la
transition énergétique semble plus
compliqué dans d'autres pays nous
parlera aussi de cet accord sur le
breakbeat et du report du vote annoncé
en début de semaine par la première
ministre britannique quelles
conséquences pour l'avenir du breakbeat
nous en discuterons avec nos invités
mais d'abord revenons sur ce drame qui a
frappé strasbourg en plein marché de
noël strasbourg capitale européenne
victime d'une fusillade en plein coeur
de son centre historique à seulement
trois kilomètres de cet hémicycle un
homme de 29 ans fish et s a tiré sur la
foule dans plusieurs rues du centre
ville
on écoute le ministre de l'intérieur
français nous sommes en france
en posture gouvernement vient de décider
de passer en urgence avec jean marais de
monts renforcé aux frontières avec aussi
la mise en place de rentrer dans le lard
en france et sur l'ensemble des marchés
de noël
et pour en discuter j'ai le plaisir
d'accueillir sur ce plateau arnaud
danjean bonjour bonjour vous êtes
français membre du parti populaire
européen ancien de la dgse et
spécialiste des questions de défense et
de renseignement à vos côtés pour
commenter cette actualité christine
revault d'allonnes bonjour bonjour vous
êtes également française membre du
groupe des socialistes et démocrates
alors arnaud danjean un première
question hier quelques heures avant la
fusillade vous étiez justement dans cet
hémicycle pour débattre de la lutte
antiterroriste est recommandé une
extrême vigilance
oui nous avons eu un débat sur cette
question de la lutte anti terroriste
parce que le parlement européen s'est
dotée depuis quinze mois d'une
commission spéciale sur ce sujet nous
remettons le rapport en ce moment même à
la session plénière de strasbourg il
sera voté mercredi et donc c'est
l'occasion d'un débat sur ce sujet et
j'avais effectivement rappelé qu' il
fallait maintenir une extrême vigilance
parce qu'il me semble que depuis
quelques mois le fait que l'état
islamique ait perdu beaucoup de position
militaire en syrie en irak que la
fréquence et l'ampleur des attentats
heureusement ne soit pas celle qu'on a
pu connaître il ya quelques années tous
à contribuer le fait aussi qu'il y ait
d'autres sujets qui éclipse un petit peu
le terrorisme tout ça faisait que bon an
mal an il me semble que notre
mobilisation est moins forte que ce
qu'elle devrait être
et donc mon point c'était de rappeler
qu'on a en face de nous des gens qui ne
sont pas les décérébrés qu'on nous
dépeint un peu rapidement ou les types
un peu paumé qui ont qui commettent des
attentats comme ça sans trop savoir
pourquoi il y à il ya des gens comme ça
mais il ya derrière tous ces gens des
organisations qui sont des organisations
djihadistes structurés organisés et
surtout extrêmement déterminé
idéologiquement et je n'ai entendu aucun
leader djihadiste ces derniers mois dire
qu'il renonçait à son combat et en
particulier à son combat contre la
france c'est un peu le sens du message
que je voulais faire passer en
n'omettant pas d'ailleurs d'autres
dimensions de la violence terroriste il
ya d'autres groupes aussi qui
apparaissent il yad'autres type
d'extrémisme qui aujourd'hui se
manifeste et qui constituent des menaces
pour notre démocratie
mais il me semble que nous restons par
rapport à la menace djihadiste parfois
un peu naïfs sur le degré de
détermination de
émouvant ce que nous avons en face de
nous alors restez vigilants justement
avec cette capitale capitale de l'europe
touché en plein coeur dans son marché de
noël un qui attire énormément de
visiteurs tous les ans plus de 2
millions christine revault d'allonnes on
a tout d'abord une très grande pensée
pour les familles des victimes et pour
les strasbourgeois dans ce moment
extrêmement difficile
nous étions nous au parlement européen
nous avions cette chance d'être protégés
dans ce confinement du parlement
européen mais nos pensées aller
directement vers ces populations ce
marché de noël il est extrêmement
sécurisé important à strasbourg
absolument ça fait un peu un certain
nombre d'années où il n'y a plus de
possibilité de prendre de s'arrêter aux
stations de tramway qui traverse le
coeur de la ville les accès des voitures
sont également interdites il y à des
fouilles des des bagages que nous
portons canton nous entrons dans cette
zone
mais malgré tout on se rend bien compte
que la vigilance doit toujours être là
et il ya toujours des risques de
faillite malheureusement alors arnaud
danjean est le chef de file de votre
parti les républicains laurent wauquiez
a déclaré qu'il fallait adapter notre
droit à la lutte contre le terrorisme
qu'est ce que vous en pensez je pense
que c'est déjà largement le cas moi je
suis pas certain que nous ayons besoin
de nouvelles dispositions législatives
on a eu en matière de renseignement en
matière de lutte antiterroriste une
accumulation de textes ces dernières
années les problèmes que nous
rencontrons sont des problèmes de
ressources la ressource humaine pour
suivre les radicaliser n'est pas
extensible à l'infini donc ça c'est une
ça paraît très prosaïque de dire ça mais
malheureusement c'est la réalité je vous
rappelle quand même qu'on a sur les
différents fichiers qui sont censés
recenser les radicaliser il y as jusqu'à
20000 non vingt mille personnes qui
demandent un suivi différencier un peu
sélectif en fonction de leur degré de
dangerosité mais en tout cas vingt mille
personnes
le suivi de 20000 personnes vous ne
pouvez pas l'assurer
24 heures sur 24 7 jours sur 7 avec les
effectifs dont nous disposons dans nos
services et dans nos polices donc
j'allais dire naturellement il y à un
risque et vous ne pourrez pas vous
pouvez le réduire au maximum et on a
fait beaucoup de progrès mais vous ne
pouvez pas avoir un dispositif à 100%
qui vous permettent d'être invulnérable
aucun pays ne peut même le pays le plus
totalitaire et le plus anti démocratique
qui soit ne peut pas se prémunir à 100%
contre les attaques terroristes
il ya eu des attaques terroristes en
russie avec des attaques terroristes en
chine et dieu sait que c'est des pays
qui vis-à-vis de l'état le droit ont des
conceptions un peu plus lâche que que
les nôtres donc bien sûr il faut faire
le maximum bien sûr on a déjà fait des
progrès et on peut sans doute faire
toujours plus mais aujourd'hui on va se
heurter très rapidement à des limites
qui sont des limites physiques
voilà par rapport à l'ampleur du
phénomène auquel on est confronté
moi je trouve par ailleurs qu'on a quand
même eu pas mal de pas mal de progrès y
compris en termes de protection physique
je pense les c'est un certain nombre de
mesures pour ne pas accéder sur des
manifestations en voiture tout ça tout
ça c'est des choses auxquelles on
pensait pas forcément il ya encore
quelques années après l'attentât de nice
voilà même des villes moyennes et
modestes mettent en place des
dispositifs les préfectures sont sont
très vigilantes sur surtout tout ça donc
voilà on progresse mais le 100%
d'invulnérabilité malheureusement
n'existe pas et n'existera jamais et au
niveau européen il en est où cette
coopération sur sur ce sujet de la lutte
antiterroriste s'est notamment l'objet
de cette de ce rapport qui est très
intéressant sur toutes les démarches de
coopération qu'il faut absolument
renforcer entre les différents services
les échanges d'informations et
le travail de partenariat donc c'était
l'objet de ce rapport de cette
commission spéciale évidemment à la fois
la commission des libertés civiles qui
est la commission plein et la commission
affaires étrangères va continuer à faire
ce travail c'est indispensable de
renforcer les tous les dispositifs et de
partage de renseignements de partage
d'informations mais aussi au niveau des
dispositifs de coopération judiciaire et
le suivi qui se doit être mené à ce
niveau là donc cette coopération
elle avance elle progresse peut-être pas
assez vite comme on le souhaiterait mais
il ya quand même un certain nombre
d'harmonisation qui sont désormais mis
sur la table et sur lequel on a
davantage de convergence qu'on pouvait
avoir il ya encore trois ou quatre
si je peux me permettre sur ce sujet moi
je pense que contrairement à une idée
reçue
je peux comprendre pourquoi le grand
public que s'interroge sur le degré de
coopération qui peut exister entre les
différents pays vu de l'intérieur
les professionnels coopèrent que ce soit
en matière de renseignement de justice
ou de policiers une coopération
intensive ya des personnes dans nos
services français qui font ça
vingt-quatre heures sur vingt-quatre
coopérer avec leurs homologues étrangers
en particulier européens donc la
coopération est sans doute beaucoup plus
intense que on l'admet publiquement
c'est vrai qu'on peut renforcer encore
certains instruments mais moi j'ai
attire toujours l'attention sur le fait
que la coop à la coopération existe déjà
un niveau très élevé et sur un cas comme
celui auquel on est confronté
aujourd'hui le problème c'est pas celui
de la coopération internationale le
problème c'est celui de la détection du
passage à l'acte et la détection du
passage à l'acte vous pouvez avoir la
meilleure coopération vous voulez avec
les allemands les italiens ou qui sait
jean perrissin 10/10/10 l'étiquette à
strasbourg et qui a décidé un matin de
passer à l'acte je crains que ça soit
pas ni la nsa ni les services italiens
ou néerlandais qui sont en mesure de
vous l'indiquer
donc il faut il faut aussi avoir
conscience que la difficulté qu'on
rencontre aujourd'hui c'est ce moment où
entre d où des personnes généralement
d'ailleurs repéré à un degré ou un autre
passe à l'acte et ça ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire c'est de l' entrave
quasiment physique qu'il faudrait faire
et une surveillance là aussi quasiment
physique donc là c'est quand même
quelque chose d'extrêmement lourd à
mettre en place et c'est face à cette
difficulté
on se trouve alors place maintenant à
l'autre actualité dominante de cette
semaine cet accord sur le brésil qui a
connu un nouveau revers avec ce report
du vote à la chambre des communes
annoncée par la première ministre
britannique en début de semaine il est
clair que même si de nombreux aspects
clés de l'accord bénéficie d'un large
soutien sur un point l'irlande du nord
l'inquiétude demeure généralisée et
profonde de sens que si nous allions de
l'avant et oignons le vote prévu
l'accord serait rejetée par une marge
significative
nous allons donc reporter le vote prévu
alors christine revault d'allonnes que
penser de ce report la première ministre
écossaise a parlé d'un gouvernement qui
s'effondre en plein chaos
elle pouvait pas mettre au vote cet
projet d'accord hier puisque c'était
mardi qu'elle devait le présenter
c'était impossible dans la mesure où
elle n'avait même plus le soutien de sa
majorité
donc elle savait qu'elle se retrouver
face à un vote contre par ailleurs la
même journée de lundi on a appris que la
cour de justice de l'union européenne
qui avaient été saisis notamment par la
cour edh écossaise avait rendu un avis
qui est extrêmement intéressant du point
de vue de la démocratie qui rappelle un
rallye avait la possibilité de revenir
pas sur l'accord de revenir sur la
décision de sortie du royaume uni de
l'union européenne dès lors que le
peuple était démocratiquement consulter
voilà ce que dit cette décision de la
cour de justice
je ne suis pas sûr que theresa may va
s'en saisir puisqu'elle n'est absolument
pas décidé à revenir sur un vote des
citoyens britanniques ce qu'on peut
entendre mais c'est quelque chose qui
est porté par un certain nombre de
personnes qui continuent à dire que la
solution d'une brique si ce n'est pas
une bonne solution ils sont toujours là
ils sont toujours extrêmement présents
et puis la décision de theresa may de
dire bon je vais juste pas d'accord
aujourd'hui mon problème principal c'est
la situation en irlande et je veux
absolument continuer à négocier pour
être sûr que l'irlande du nord reste
bien dans le royaume uni n'est pas de
disposition à faciliter des échanges
avec l'union européenne c'est un point
sur lequel on ne doit pas négocier
c'est notre projet d'accord on ne
reviendra pas dessus une certaine
confusion en effet autour de cet accord
comme en témoignent ses réactions
commençons par celle de guy verhofstadt
représentant pour le breakbeat au
parlement européen qui déclare sur
twitter je ne suis plus après deux ans
de négociations le gouvernement
conservateur veut reporter le vote
il est temps qu'il se décide vives
réactions également de jérémy cording
chef de file des travaillistes le
gouvernement a décidé que l'accord sur
le président de theresa may et si
désastreux qu'il a choisi l'option
désespérée de reporter son propre vote à
la onzième heure alors arnaud danjean
une motion de défiance a été déposée à
l'encontre du gouvernement de teresa
mais qu'est ce que ça signifie pour
l'avenir du breakbeat
bon bah c'est une tous que ce à quoi
nous assistons depuis 48 heures c'est
sont des vicissitudes de plus mais pas
totalement surprenante dans un débat qui
est devenue malheureusement qui n'est
plus le débat du bric site qui est un
débat britanno britannique sur l'avenir
politique de madame mai et qui veut
accéder au pouvoir
le bric site est complètement perdu dans
toutes les considérations qu'on entend
que ce soit chez les conservateurs ou
chez les travaillistes
le deal qui est sur la table tout le
monde l'a répété je crois que c'est
sincère c'est plutôt un bon deal pour
faire un divorce à l'amiable qu'ils
soient le moins coûteux possible pour
les deux parties est aujourd'hui un
problème c'est ce filet de sécurité qui
26 ans mais ça c'est le prétexte
ça c'est le prétexte qu'ils aient donné
c'est le prétexte qu'ils aient donné
parce que monsieur corps been par
exemple travailliste ils devraient voter
cet accord il devrait apporter son
soutien à madame est mais on voit bien
que ce qui l'intéresse lui c'est pas du
tout ça ce qui m'intéresse c'est d'aller
le plus vite possible aux élections pour
espérer remplacer madame mai donc c'est
pas du tout des considérations sur le
break site qui l'amène à prendre sa
position idem pour les briques sitter
les plus durs à l'intérieur du parti
conservateur
leur but c'est de faire chuter madame
mais est de pouvoir se compter à
l'intérieur du parti conservateur c'est
pas du tout de savoir si les
dispositions sont plus ou moins
favorable il faut qu'ils comprennent
qu'ils n'auront pas de dispositions plus
favorables mais il faut être un peu
rationnelle à un moment le problème
c'est que plus personne ne l'est dans
cette affaire je trouve que l'union
européenne les rationnels et que barnier
et son équipe et les chefs d'état ou de
gouvernement qui lui ont apporté un
soutien unanime unanime faut le rappeler
une époque où on nous dit
l'europe se divise sur tout et n'importe
quoi il ya unies sur le sujet qui est
pas un petit sujet pardonnez moi qui ai
quand même celui du break site dont on
disait c'était le début de la fin pour
l'europe
moi je constate que les 27 chefs d'état
et de gouvernement quelle que soit leur
opinion politique quel que soit le côté
sulfureux de ces gens ou pas ces gens là
se sont mis d'accord pour soutenir le
deal qui est sur la table
donc là il ya un peu de rationalité côté
union européenne d un côté c'est la
meilleure porte de sortie qu'on puisse
avoir pour tout le monde pour préserver
les intérêts et les intérêts mutuels et
puis on a un certain nombre de gens en
grande bretagne qui encore une fois pour
des jeux politiciens refusent d'entrer
dans le vrai débat de fond et de
substances sur le pré xi et veulent
simplement faire des coups médiatiques
et politiques et ça c'est absolument
tragique pour le paix pour le pays et
pour le veau le royaume uni qui est un
grand pays quelques grandes démocraties
mais enfin là il ya quand même un
dévoiement de la démocratie qui est
terrible parce qu'il s'en faire dans un
débat qui n'a plus de rationalité
merci beaucoup à tous les deux d'avoir
été nos invités aujourd'hui nous prenons
maintenant la direction de la suède pays
modèle en matière de transition
énergétique puisqu'il devrait atteindre
dès la fin de cette année les objectifs
fixés pour 2030 alors que la fiscalité
verte est à l'origine en france de la
vague de protestations des gilet jaune
la suède est parvenue à instaurer une
taxe carbone il ya plus de 25 ans
comment les quelques 10 millions de
suédois vive t-il cet engagement
environnemental
nos reporters sandra cerqueira et fabien
becker sont allés à leur rencontre
à stockholm le transport urbain se passe
de diesel les bus roulent au
biocarburant depuis des années et plus
personne ne s'en étonne 80 mille tonnes
de co2 sont ainsi économisés chaque
année c'est aussi 70% de particules
fines en moins bien sûr que chacun
d'entre nous veut de l'air respirable
nous avons une voiture mais nous ne
l'utilisons pas en ville nous prenons le
but pour nous déplacer et dès qu'on peut
on marche c'est un pays qui s'est
transformée en une génération
la création d'une taxe carbone en 1991 a
permis de tourner le dos aux énergies
fossiles en changeant les comportements
fredrik habite en banlieue de stockholm
comme beaucoup de suédois il a changé
son système de chauffage consomme et du
fioul devenait beaucoup plus cher alors
il a investi dans cette pompe à chaleur
géothermique qui va chercher dans le sol
les calories qui permettent de produire
de l'énergie
christophe agent s'est vite devenue très
rentable
nous l'avons achetée il ya vingt ans la
pompe couvre nos besoins en eau chaude
et chauffage quasiment toute l'année et
c'est le cas de tout le monde dans le
quartier
plus personne n'utilise de fioul pour se
chauffer selon lui la taxe carbone fait
consensus
car elle a été mise en place de façon
progressive et avec une fiscalité en
faveur de l'environnement incitatives et
non punitive
comme avec les déchets le ramassage des
ordures alimentaire et gratuit le reste
est payé au kilo ce plus on réduit ses
déchets plus on fait des économies
mais je dois dire que je ne le fais pas
pour les économies mais pour
l'environnement
la suède possède aujourd'hui la taxe
carbone avec le prix le plus élevé au
monde
120 euros par tonne de co2 elle a ainsi
divisé par deux ses émissions de gaz à
effet de serre mais tout cela ne s'est
pas fait sans contrepartie cette taxe
sur les émissions de co2 a été mise en
place en parallèle d'une baisse de
l'impôt sur le revenu ou le capital
l'esprit de ce système fiscal c'est de
taxer ce qui est négatif c'est-à-dire
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre
plutôt que ce qui est positif comme les
petites économies où le travail
et puis en suède les gens font plutôt
confiance au gouvernement pour
réinvestir et redistribuer cet argent à
bon escient c'est aussi grâce à cette
taxe carbone que les carburants verts
ont pu se développer en suède une partie
du biogaz utilisé par les bus et
fabriqués dans cette usine de
méthanisation situé à quelques
kilomètres de stockholm
ici arrivent chaque jour des tonnes de
déchets ménagers venu tout droit des
poubelles des particuliers ou des
restaurants pour produire l'équivalent
de 5000 tonnes de carburant vert il faut
50 mille tonnes de déchets c'est dans
les digesteurs que les bactéries ont
transformé la matière organique en
l'état mais en co2 et en forme forme
biogaz et
après j'espère une phase gazeuse qui va
être traitée séparément pour faire du
biocarburant est une phase liquide qui
va être traitée séparément pour faire
des composts des fertilisants agricoles
un cercle vertueux qui permet de
fabriquer une énergie renouvelable
compétitive on peut proposer un prix à
la pompe et 10 à 15 centimes d'euros
moins cher que les carburants fossiles
parce que le biogaz al'avantage de ne
pas payer la taxe carbone à une taxe
carbone qui concerne tout le monde sauf
qu'aujourd'hui en suède les entreprises
n'en payent que 60% contre 100 % pour
les particuliers
pour ce député écologiste cet écart doit
disparaître le gouvernement suédois a
beaucoup oeuvré ces dernières années
dans le cadre d'un plan climat pour
augmenter la taxe carbone pour les
industries
mais il faut aller plus loin le prix du
carbone doit être plus élevés dans tous
les secteurs qui polluent au niveau
européen par exemple concernant les
transports il ya encore des efforts à
faire en taxant davantage le trafic
aérien et la suède a commencé depuis
avril dernier à taxer ses vols
intérieurs
alors que les émissions de co2 des
énergies fossiles augmentent en europe
la suède elle s'est engagée à atteindre
le zéro carbone d'ici 2040 5
[Musique]
et pour en discuter j'ai le plaisir
d'accueillir sur ce plateau michèle
rivasi bonjour à vos shows vous êtes
française vous appartenait au groupe des
verts et vous êtes rapporteur sur la
gouvernance de l'union de l'énergie
alors on vient de voir ce reportage avec
ces suédois finalement qu'ils acceptent
bien cette fiscalité verte
qu'est ce que ça vous inspire quoi
écouter il faudrait le faire passer à
plaindre au gouvernement français parce
que c'est vraiment un pays vertueux ils
ont tout compris ils ont taxé
effectivement le carbone mais ils ont
redistribué c'est à dire qu'ils ont
diminué les impôts pour parce que vous
pouvez pas toujours demander de payer si
les gens en retour vois pas autre chose
il ya une fiscalité verte mais en
contrepartie l'impôt
exactement et puis il ya une
augmentation de service public regardez
au niveau des villes il ya énormément de
bus
donc les gens peuvent très bien prendre
les transports en commun et en même
temps moi j'ai beaucoup aimé sur tout ce
qui est bio gaz c'est à dire que ont
produit des déchets de ces déchets en
produits du gaz et ceux gasser aux
voitures et en même temps là il ya une
différence entre les biogaz voyez où
l'essence est moins cher que l'essence
qui est issue justement des énergies
fossiles ça une résonance particulière
avec ce mouvement d gilet jaune ans
qu'on observe au ils manifestent contre
les prix de l'essence mais exactement
parce qu'il n'y a pas de contrepartie
c'est-à-dire on a taxé les français mais
on ne redistribue pas les taxes pour
aider à la transition et et énergétiques
et dimanche dernier voyez j'étais à la
raffinerie de la mède à marseille et
pourquoi j'étais là bas parce que total
veut faire du bio diesel pourquoi pas
mais il importe entre 300 et 500 mille
tonnes d'huile de palme voyez l'huile de
palme c'est la déforestation en
indonésie
ça produit trois fois plus de gaz à
effet de serre voyez que le diesel
classique donc en france on marche sur
la tête
et ce reportage montre bien la cohérence
à la fois on a un gouvernement assez
vertueux dans sa façon de fonctionner
mais il montre l'exemple
et puis en même temps sur les déchets
parce qu'on est des producteurs de
déchets incroyable et bien on fabrique
de l'énergie sur les transports
on incite les gens à utiliser des
transports collectifs parce que soit ils
sont gratuits ou à faible coût
sur l'énergie le chauffage ce que c'est
un gros souci
en france le quotidien vis-à-vis des
gilet jaune quand on les écoute
c'est le logement des chauffages le
logement il faut absolument voir des
loyers faible parce que si le smig vous
avez 100% de votre smic qui passe au
niveau du logement vous faites quoi pour
vivre et puis le chauffage ils sont trés
sur la géothermie
alors que non en france on est resté sur
les énergies fossiles qui n'a pas une
chaudière à fuel qui n'utilisent pas du
fuel voiliers ou même au niveau de ces
tracteurs etc dans le monde agricole est
bien là la géothermie est très utilisé
en suède et je trouve que c'est pas
assez utilisé en france alors qu'ils
sont sur une économie circulaire si ça
le modèle vertueux alors justement un
michèle rivasi ce débat en france un
lieu en même temps que la conférence
mondiale sur le climat la coop 24 en
pologne à katowice et on écoute le
secrétaire général des nations unies qui
s'exprimait au deuxième jour de cette
conférence
it is plein brouillard way home n'allons
pas du tout dans la bonne direction
nous avons besoin de plus d'actions et
d'ambition et nous devons absolument
combler cet écart démission si nous
échouons vif l'arctique et l'antarctique
continueront à fond quand les gourous
beau blanchir et mourir les océans vont
s'élever de plus en plus de personnes
mourant de la pollution de l'air la
pénurie d'eau affectera une part
importante de l'humanité et le coût des
catastrophes montera en flèche
c'est un constat terrible l'urgence
climatique elle n'est plus à prouver et
pourtant la coop 24 a été boudé par un
grand nombre de dirigeants mais je pense
que nos dirigeants sont pas à la hauteur
des enjeux
j'ai écouté antonio guterres s lorsqu'il
dit c'est une question de vie ou de mort
moi même je suis à la délégation des
pays acp afrique caraïbes pacifique et
il voit bien que ça y est par exemple
aux fidji que vous soyez au samoa tout
ça les îles si vous deviennent submergé
par la hausse du niveau de l'argent
qu'ils vont devenir des réfugiés
climatiques si on ne fait pas exactement
mais déjà aujourd'hui
et même nous on le ressent les
dérèglements climatiques voyez quand
vous voyez toutes ces tempêtes ces
inondations etc
on voit qu'il ya des phénomènes de plus
en plus violents donc il faut qu'on
change de modèle
il faut qu'on change de comportement
mais on a un tel poids d'abord de
culture on a un tel poids des lobbys qui
ne veulent pas changer parce qu'ils sont
sur le profit immédiat moi il ya un mot
qui m'a touché sur les gilet jaune qui
me touche
quand on va en afrique ou ailleurs c'est
ce mot injustices les inégalités
voyez temps qu'on n'arrive pas à
résoudre ça en redistribuant les
richesses en partageant mais avec
justement un cercle vertueux comme on a
vu sur votre reportage eh bien les gens
ne se sentiront pas associée or on a une
seule planète mais comment tout faire en
même temps ça on allait heureusement je
vois souvent des comptes le giec ce
groupement intergouvernemental sur
l'évolution du climat nous dit vous avez
12 ans pour changer de modèle est
vraiment réduire les gaz à effet de
serre alors l'europe à sa part moi même
vous avez dit j'étais à porter sur la
gouvernance de l'énergie on a dit 2030
minimum 45 % il faudra aller à 65% et
c'est bien au niveau de l'europe qu'on
peut avoir une action coordonnée et
harmonisée et que tout le monde à y
voyait sur la sauvegarde de la planète
il ya un écart entre les dirigeants et
les mouvements qu'on voit ces marches
pour le climat la dernière à bruxelles
qui a rassemblé qui 65000 personnes
il ya un véritable écart entre ces gens
cette population qui se mobilisent et
ses dirigeants
il ya un écart parce que les gens le
sens profondément et ils ont envie de
donner un futur à leurs enfants et
comment on agit alors d'abord moi je
crois beaucoup au local il ya énormément
d'initiatives oui il faut pas être
pessimiste il ya plein de gens qui font
des choses
voyez moi je suis issu d'un département
la drogue c'est le département le plus
bio de france et ce à un coût tout ça
aussi égoutter ça n'a pas forcément un
coup dans la mesure où quand vous avez
des producteurs bio qui s'organise et
qui distribue eux mêmes
voyez vous enlever toute la distribution
et c'est tout à fait le même niveau que
si vous avez en grande surface on change
de modèle par une date d'achat on change
le mode agricole alors cette coop 24,1 a
lieu
en pologne qui fait partie des pays qui
émettent le plus de co2 liées à
l'énergie juste derrière l'allemagne
on écoute le président polonais faut
respecter un équilibre
on ne peut pas réaliser une politique
climatique contre la volonté de nos
sociétés the score avec des effets
négatifs sur le niveau de confirmer aux
tchétchènes niveau de vie contre
politique climatique
est-ce qu'il faut vraiment opposé ces
deux notions connues mais il faut quand
même montrer aux gens la voie qu'il faut
suivre en pologne
ils ont toujours vécu avec des mines de
charbon mine de charbon très gros
émetteur de sony donc on va pas pouvoir
changer du jour au lendemain il faut
qu'on fasse une transition en même temps
c'est des pays qui n'ont pas beaucoup la
culture sur les énergies renouvelables
moi j'y suis allée voyez un moment ils
voulaient vraiment développer les gaz de
schiste séparé gaz de schiste voyez ces
fracturation hydraulique
ces pollutions des nappes etc ils ont
fini par à peu près abandonné donc il
faut aller sur des énergies
renouvelables progressivement et en
montrant contrat contrainte c'est à dire
leur dire vous avez mettons dix ans mais
il faut absolument changer de modèle
mais regardez nous la france on a ce
nucléaire là qui peut nous souhaiter
demain avec nos vieilles centrales
eh bien on aggrave aussi augmenté nos
gaz à effet de serre donc vous voyez que
c'est qu'un tout le modèle
il n'ya pas seulement la production
d'énergie il ya aussi les transports il
ya aussi le chauffage mais aussi le
logement tout ça c'est par un ensemble
de choses qu'on réduira notre
consommation énergétique
parce que d'abord il faut être sur la
sobriété et je préfère ce terme sobriété
heureuse
- gaz depuis al à une sommation voilà
diminuer notre consommation avec des
produits de plus bonne qualité d'où
l'intérêt du bio et ses terrasses en
substance chimique et puis d'être
responsable et de faire en sorte à ce
que le travail soit en lien avec les
lieux d'habitat oui pour diminuer les
transports s'est pas empêché la mobilité
mais c'est faire quelque chose qui est
plus cohérent pour défendre notre
planète
merci beaucoup michèle rivasi d'avoir
été notre invité aujourd'hui merci à
vous de nous avoir suivis c'est comme ça
c'est ainsi que se termine notre
émission
aujourd'hui vous pouvez la retrouver en
replay 1 sur nos différents sites ftp n
public sénat et rtbf.be belle semaine à
tous et à très bientôt
[Musique]